[موسيقى]
مساء الخير لماذا يلحق الرئيس التركي
اردوغان على لقاء الرئيس السوري بشار
الاسد هذا الالحاح بدات تلميح الموضوع عده
شهور ثم صرح به علنا في 27 نوفمبر الماضي
عندما قال بعد مصافحته للرئيس المصري في
العاصمه القطريه الدوحه لاول مره يمكن ان
نبدا مسار للتطبيع العلاقات مع سوريا
والرئيس بشار الاسد
وبرد ذلك بانه لا توجد عدوات دائمه في
السياسه وحدد مسار لعمليه التطبيع التي
يسعى اليها مع الاسد وهو لقاء على مستوى
وزراء الدفاع ثم لقاء على مستوى وزراء
الخارجيه ثم لقاء على مستوى القاده في
منتصف العام الجاري 2023 وضع خطا تحت
منتصف العام الجاري لان التوقيت له دلاله
ما الهدف الذي يدفع اردوغان للالحاح على
لقاء الاسد ولماذا يتردد الاسد في
الاستجابه لهذا المطلب فيما يتعلق بالسؤال
الاول لا ترهق نفسك كثيرا بالبحث والتحليل
عن اهداف كثير من التوجهات والقرارات
الخارجيه والداخليه لاردوغان في الشهور
الماضيه وفي الشهور التلاوه وحتى يونيو
المقبل لان معظم هذه القرارات محركها
الرئيسي هو رغبه اردوغان وحزبه في الفوز
في الانتخابات المقبله 2003
كيف يمكن ان يساهم لقاء الاسد في فوز
اردوغان في الانتخابات المقبله لان هذا
اللقاء يمكن ان يحقق له هدفين اساسيين
يمكن ان يعزز من فرص الحزب واردوغان في
الفوز في الانتخابات الهدف الاول هو
مساعده اردوغان في الضرب واضعاف الجماعات
الكرديه المسلحه وتحديدا قوات سوريا قد
الديمقراطيه او قصد الموجوده في شمال شرق
سوريا والهدف الثاني مساعده الاتراك في
اعاده اكبر عدد ممكن من اللاجئين السوريين
الى بلدهم
الهدف الاول تحدثنا عنه كثيرا وهو العلاقه
المطربه بين تركيا وبين اكراد سوريا وبين
الاكراد في كل مكان في العالم خصوصا
الجامعات الكرديه اللي لها طموحات
انفصاليه او لها طموحات على الاقل في
اقامه والتمتع بحكم ذاتي في بلدانه وفي
الحاله اللي احنا بنتكلم عليها
هي سوريا ارجعوا لحلقه سابقه سوف اضع لكم
روابطها حتى لنكررها ما جاء فيها
والهدف الثاني اللي احنا بنركز عليه في
هذه الحلقه هو اعاده اكبر عدد ممكن من
اللاجئين
اللاجئين الاجانب الموجودين على الاراضي
التركيه تحولوا الى واحد من القضايا
الداخليه الضاغطه على الرئيس التركي وحزبه
واصبحت قضيه انتخابيه بامتياز
الكثير من الاتراك بداوا يتمللون من
السوريين وغير السوريين من الاجانب
والسؤال لماذا الان سببين
السبب الاول انه تركيا على مدار السنوات
ال 10 الماضيه
او ال12 سنه الماضيه فتحت ابوابها على
مصانعها لكل انواع اللاجئين والاجانب
لاسباب مختلفه يمكن ان نتحدث عنها في وقت
لاحق كانت في طموحات وتوجهات سياسيه ورغبه
في التاثير في اماكن نفوذ تركيا في اا
اسيا الوسطى في الشرق الاوسط في دول كثيره
وكان واحد من وسائل تنفيذ همم او يعني
زياده النفوذ التركي في هذه الاماكن هو
فتحه ابواب الهجره للاجئين من هذه البلدان
ولي تركيا اللي كان بيرغب اردوغان ان هي
تكون عاصمه لكل العالم الاسلامي السني على
كل الاحوال
نتيجه السياسه
السياسه الابواب المفتوحه على مطار اكثر
من عشر سنوات
استقبلت تركيا الان مجموعه عدد كبير
ملايين من اللاجئين من العراق ومن ايران
ومن اسيا الوسطى ومن مصر وليبيا وطبعا
نصيب الاسد كان للسوريين بدايه من 2011 من
خلال موجات من الهجره المتعاقبه على
الاراضي التركيه
هؤلاء اللاجئين همم اعدادهم الحقيقه حصرها
صعب لانه هم تحت تصنيفات مختلفه لكن
الارقام الرسميه الحديثه بتقول انه على
الاراضي التركيه بيوجد حوالي خمسه ونصف
مليون لاجئ يتمتعون بالحمايه المؤقته يعني
المؤقت
ودول يعني همم ثلاثه وسبعه من 10 منهم
مليون سوري
اضف الى ذلك حوالي مليون
و400,000 يحصلون على اقامات عندهم تصاريح
اقامه اما لانهم طلاب او مستثمرين الى
اخره وهناك حوالي 350 الف شخص يطلبون
اللجوء السياسي من دول مختلفه اضف الى
الثلاث اصناف السابقه
عندك سائحين يعني اجانب حصلوا على تصاريح
سياحه لكنهم في حقيقه الامر كانوا راغبين
في الحصول على وظائف وبالتالي تخلفوا
وبقوا في تركيا وسعوا للحصول على وظائف
اضف الى كل هؤلاء طبعا المهاجرين غير
الشرعيه اللي تسللوا الى البلاد كما
يتسللون الى غيرها غيرها من البلدان تركيا
منذ يعني شهور قليله فعلت سياسه بمقتضاءها
يستطيع الانسان الحصول على اقامه دائمه او
الجنسيه اذا حصل على عقار قيمته واظن في
حدود 400 الف دولار او اكثر مما زاد
الطينه بالله النتيجه انه بقى في اعداد
ضخمه لا تقل عن ثمانيه مليون اجنبي وفقا
لتقديرات بعض الاحزاب المعارضه وساءت
الاوضاع اكثر وضاق التراكم اكثر واكثر
بالاجانب مع سوء الاوضاع الاقتصاديه
كانت الاوضاع الاقتصاديه الجديده في 2014
و15 و16 ثم بدات في التدهور من اخر 2017
و18 وطبعا وصلت ذرواتيا في 2021 و22 وهناك
اكثر من حلقه تحدثنا فيها عن تدهر الاوضاع
الاقتصاديه التركيه سوف اضع لكم روابتها
حتى لا نكرر ما جاء فيها اذا زياده اعداد
الاجانب على الاراضي التركيه بسبب
السياسات الحكوميه على مدار اكثر من 12
سنه وتدهر الاوضاع الاقتصاديه افرزا موجه
من رفض الوجود الاجنبي على الاراضي
التركيه
ووجدنا انه احزاب المعارضه بتضغط على
الحزب الحاكم وعلى الرئيس اردوغان وبتقول
لو وصلنا الى السلطه سوف نستجيب الى هذه
المطالب الشعبيه ونعيد الاجانب الى
بلدانهم وعلى راسهم السوريين اللي هيعود
وفقا ليه الاحزاب المعارضه الى بلدانهم
خلال عامين من تولهم السلطه وجدنا ان في
حزب جديد اظن اسمه حزب النصر جعل من قضيه
التخلص من اللاجئين برنامج او على راس
اولوياته اذا وصل الى البرلمان او الى
السلطه
الرئيس اردوغان بيراقب ما يجري وهو حريص
في اطار حرصه على الفوز في حرثه على الفوز
في الانتخابات يريد ان يسحب هذه الورقه من
ايدي المعارضه انتم تريدون الفوز على
تذكره اعاده اللاجئين وبتالي تهدئه غضب
جانب كبير من الشارع التركي طيب انا سوف
اسعى لتحقيق هذا الهدف ولكوني في السلطه
انا اكثر منكم قدر على تحقيق هذه الخطوه
وبالتالي بدا منذ فتره من ماي والماضي
علنا بيتحدث عن رغبته في اعاده اللاجئين
السوريين الى بلدانهم وقال في تصريح وقتها
نحن نجحنا في حمايه هؤلاء المقهورين
والمستضعفين من يعني الباتش اللي لحق بهم
في بلدانهم والان نسعى الى اعادتهم الى
بلدانهم ولكنها عوده طوعيه وبدا بالفعل
يشيد بعض
المدن اللي موجوده في شمال سوريا ويهمهد
الى عوده بعضهم اعداد صغيره ومنظمات حقوق
انسان بتقول انهم اعيدوا الى هذه المنطقه
بالقوه لكن دي قصه يطول شرحها
في هذا الاطار رغبته في تحقيق الهدفين ضرب
الجماعات الكرديه وهدف طويل الامل ومطلوب
الان وامس واول امس وغدا وبعد غد لكنه
يزداد اهميه في اوقات الانتخابات لانه ضرب
هذه الجماعات حتى ولم الجماعات الكرديه
المسلحه حتى لو لم تكن تمثل تحديدا مباشره
على تركيا وحتى لو قدمت تقنيات لتركيا
بانها لا تستهدفها ولم تستهدفها فضرب هذه
الجماعات يدعم ال- يعني فرص اردوغان في
الانتخابات لانه سوف يظهر باعتباره الرجل
الذي يحمي البلد يحمي وطنه ابناءه من اي
احتمالات
لتهديد الامن القومي التركي وهناك قناه
على ده كثير من القوه التركيه سواء في
السلطه او حتى خارج السلطه بان واحد من
اكبر المخاطر على الامن القومي التركي هو
نجاح اي جماعه كرديه في اقامه حكم ذاتي او
في الانفصال عن بلدها لان هذا يعني انه
تشجيع
للكورد وهم ملايين داخل تركيا بانهم
يحدثهم وبالتالي هذا يفتت التركيه
سواء كان هذا الخطر حقيقي ام متوهم فهو
واحد من الاهداف الثابته للرئيس اردوغان
ولغيره وطبعا احنا عارفين ان الحكومه
التركيه مشتركه مع حزب العمال الكردستاني
اللي بتعتبره حزب ارهابي منذ اوائل
الثمانينيات وطلاحقه في كل مكان خصوصا في
سوريا وفي العراق على كل الاحوال
الهدفين دول الرئيس التركي سعى الى
تحقيقهما بكل السبل ولكن نقدر نميز ثلاث
مراحل رئيسه على مدار ال 12 سنه الماضيه
او ال 10 سنوات الماضيه على الاقل في ال
10 سنوات الماضيه في المرحله الاولى
الساعه لتحقيق الهدفين ضربه الجامعات
الكرديه واعاده توطين اللاجئين من خلال
دعوه للمجتمع الدولي والدول الغربيه
والدول الخليجيه اللي كان بيمثل معها
جابها لاسقاط حكومه بشار الاسد وهذه قصه
تحدثنا عنها كثيرا قبل ذلك وطالب الولايات
المتحده وطالب حلف شمال الاطلسي اللي هو
عضو فيه بان هم يساعدوه على اقامه منطقه
حضر طيران في شمال سوريا
وفي شمال سوريا سوف يقيم منطقه امنه بطول
بعمق حوالي 30 كيلو متر وعلى طول الحدود
مع سوريا اللي هي حوالي 900 كيلو مترا
طبعا على اطول مسافه ممكنه وتحت حمايه
الطيران واسلحه الدفاع الجوي الغربيه
وبدعم ماليا من الاتحاد الاوروبي سوف يقيم
مدنا كامله يعيد اليها اللاجئين اللي
موجودين اللي تسللوا الى تركيا او اللي
دخلوا بشكل قانوني الى تركيا واذا نجح في
تحقيق ده كان مخططه في اقامه هذه المنطقه
الامنه وتوطين اللاجئين السوريين فيها كان
هيحقق مجموعه من الاهداف الهدف الاولاني
طبعا ضرب الجماعات الكرديه وابعادها عن
الحدود الا هتتحول الى منطقه عازله بين
هؤلاء القرد واي خطر محتمل من جانبهم وبين
الحدود الجنوبيه لتركيا ثانيا سوف يتخلص
من عبق اللاجئين وليس على نفقته الخاصه
ولكن باموال الاتحاد الاوروبي اللي هيبني
مدن كامله يستقبل فيها هؤلاء اللاجئين
من سوف يقيم المدن شركات المقاولات
التركيه وهي شركات ضخمه جدا ونشطه في
تركيا وخارج تركيا وبالتالي زياده في
انعاش الاقتصاد التركي ثم ثم انه معنى ذلك
انه اذا اقام هذه
المنطقه بمباركه دوليه يستطيع ان يحقق
اهداف اخرى منها انه يستطيع ان يبطل مثلا
كثير من الجماعات المتطرفه اللي بينتقد او
اللي انتقد لاحقا لايوائها
ويعيش في هذه الاماكن ويكون اا يعني سيفا
مصلاتا على النظام السوري في وقت في اي
وقت لاحق في المستقبل ويمكن توظيفه في اي
ساعه من ساحات المعارك همم الكثيره اللي
تركيه مشتركه فيها استخدمهم مثلا في ليبيا
واستخدمهم في ساحات اخرى
والهدف النهائي سوف يتحقق وهو السيطره على
كامل شمال سوريا لانه السيطره على كامل
شمال سوريا حلم تركي قديم وبيعتقدوا ان
هذا الجزء ما كان له ان ينتزع من تركيا زي
بالضبط شمال العراق
واصدقائنا الكرد بيتحدثوا منذ سنوات عن
حلم تركيا في اقامه ما يسمى او تنفيذ ما
يسمى بالميثاق الملي ما هو الميثاق المللي
قصه طويله يمكن ان نعود اليها لاحقا ولكن
هو السيطره على هذا الجزء من الاراضي
السوريه اللي بيعتبروه جزءا تاريخيا ما
كان لتركيا ان تتخلى عنه بعد الحرب
العالميه الاولى وهزيمتها في هذه الحرب
اهداف كثيره وتخيلوا بقى انه هيحتل او
يسيطر على هذه المنطقه ويبقى ليه نفوذ
كامل وقول نهائي في اي امر يتعلق بشمال
سوريا وفي قضايا اخرى كثيره مرتبطه
بقضيه السوريه
المخطط في مرحلته الاولى فشل لانه حلف
شمال الاطلسي الولايات المتحده الاتحاد
الاوروبي احجم عن تنفيذ هذا المخطط لاسباب
ان يطول شرحها وازداد تنفيذ هذا المخطط
صعوبه بعد دخول روسيا الى ساحه الحرب في
2015 وبالتالي
لم يعد من الممكن الحلف شمال الاطلسي ان
يستجيب للطالب اردوغان باقامه حظر جوي
ويدخل في مواجهه مع الروس هناك ثم مع
الفوضى اللي اعقبت اضعاف النظام التدخل
التركي اضعف النظام السوري لكنه لم يسقطه
وترتب على اضعافه نشطت جماعات ارهابيه زي
داعش وغيرها وبالتالي اراد الغرب محاربه
هذه الجمعات التي يمكن ان مات ان تضرب
مصالحه في منطقه الشرق الاوسط ثم تتسلل
الى الغرب وتضرب مصالحه ايضا فاراد ان
يضرب هذه الجماعات ولم يجد هناك جماعه
واحده تستطيع ان تعينه على اداء هذه
المهمه الا
القوات الكرديه المسلحه التي كانت تتمتع
بالانقبات والكفاءه ونجحت في استئصال شوكه
هذه الجماعات الجانب منها كان بيحضر
بتاييد ولو غير مباشر من
القوات من الاجهزه الامن التركيه
التالي اا ال- السياسه باك فاير يعني
اللي كان بيتبعها لتحقيق اهدافه ادت الى
نتائج عكسيه ازدادت قوه ونفوذ الجماعات
الكرديه
وتعثر فكره اعاده اللاجئين الى سوريا
فانتقل الى مرحله اخرى لتحقيق الهدفين ضرب
الجماعات الكرديه واعاده اللاجئين من خلال
التدخل العسكري التركي المباشر اللي يسعى
في نهايه المطاف للسيطره على شمال سوريا
واقامه المنطقه الامنه وبالتالي ضرب
الجماعات الكرديه واعاده اللاجئين كم
عمليه عسكريه من 2016 اربع عمليات واحده
في ادلب استبعدوها قليلا
وثلاث عمليات مباشره لضرب الجماعات
الكرديه وبالتالي السيطره على شمال سوريا
تمهيدا لاقامه المنطقه الامنه لتحقيق
الهدفين
العمليات الثلاثه في شمال سوريا او نقول
اربع عمليات اسفرت في نهايه المطاف على
سيطره تركيا على حوالي 10% من كم المساحه
سوريا لكنها لم تنجح حتى هذه اللحظه في
تحقيق الهدفين لا الضرب الجماعات الكرديه
تماما ولا استطاع اعاده اللاجئين كما
يتمنى فبدا في التفكير في عمليه رابعه في
شمال سوريا او خامسه في كامل الاراضي
السوريه وبيهدد بهذه العمليه منذ مايو
الماضي يونيو الماضي نوفمبر ديسمبر لكن
هذه العمليه يهدد بها ولا يستطيع تنفيذها
وقلنا الاسباب لو عايزين تعرفوا لماذا لم
يستطع ارجعه لحلقه بعنوان همم سحب الحرب
تتجمع فوق سوريا سوف اضع لكم رابطها
ببساطه لانه القوه الرئيسه الداتا النفور
همم في سوريا ترفض عمليه عسكريه خامسه لا
الامريكان يريدون عمليه تضرب حليفهم
الرئيسي اللي هم الكورد ولا روسيا ولا
ايران ترحب بهذه العمليه في كبير في
المصالح عجز الرئيس التركي حتى هذه اللحظه
عن تنفيذ العمليه الخامسه
فانتقل الى المرحله الثالثه او للاليه
الثالثه لتحقيق هدفيه اللي بيسعى لتحقيقهم
من 2012 وعجز ضرب الجامعات الكرديه واعانه
اللاجئين وهو بتصالح مع الرئيس بشار الاسد
المنطق وراء التصالح مع بشار الاسد منطق
بسيط جدا انا عجزت عن اسقاتك واعجزت عن
همم يعني دعم الوصول بنظام موال هي ليه
على حسابك فيه ده مشق وانت لاسباب واضحه
نجحت بحلفائك الروس والايرانيين ان تفرض
الامر الواقع وان تظل كرئيسا لي سوريا حتى
وان تقلص نفودك حتى وان ضعف جيشك
مازلت انت رئيس سوريا وبالتالي بما انه ال
ال ال ال المخطط الاول فشل المخطط الثاني
فشل فهناك مخطط ثالث لتحقيق الهدفين من
خلال المفاوضات والتصالح مع بشار الاسد
التصور التركي بقدرتهم على تحقيق هذين
الهدفين من خلال التصالح مع بشار الاسد
مبني على مجموعه من الاعتبارات
والالامنيات واحد من هذه الاعتبارات ان
هناك مصالح مشتركه بين انقره
وااشق على الاقل فيما يتعلق بالهدف الاول
اللي هو الضرب الجماعات الكرديه
الاتراك يريدون ضرب هذه الجماعات وادي
دمشق لا تمانع في ضرب هذه الجامعات لان
وجود هذه الجماعات بهذا النفوذ يعني
قدرتها على فرض امر واقع والحصول
يعني كادع في الايمان على منطقه حكم ذاتي
وهم بيتمتعوا بالفعل بمنطقه حكم ذاتي
وبيسيطروا على مساحات واسعه من شمال شرق
سوريا بدعم من الولايات المتحده
وبالتالي اذا تعاون بدمشق وانقره يمكن
لهما ان يعني يحققها هذا الهدف في اضعافات
الجماعات الكرديه دمشق لا تريد هذه
الجماعات ان تسيطر على مساحه واسعه ضرب
هذه الجماعات واضعافها من جانب تركيا
بمباركه من الرئيس بشار الاسد سوف يسمح لي
بشار الاسد باستعاده سيادته على المساحه
واسعه في شمال شرق سوريا هذا مطلوب في حد
ذاته ومطلوب اكثر لان شمال شرق سوريا بيضم
كثير من الثروات البترول والغاز ومساحات
واسعه من الاراضي وبالتالي الرئيس بشار في
يمثل حاجه للحصول على عوائد هذه الثروات
لانقاذ اقتصاده الماذون
وفي التوقيت ده يكون افضل قبل ان يتم وضع
دستور الجديد ينص على امتيازات لا يريدها
بشار الاسد للقرد تحت يعني ضغوط الامر
الواقع ووجودهم وقوتهم في شمال شرق سوريا
في التقاء الى حد كبير في هذا الملف
الايرانيين لا يمانعون الروس يمكن ان
يبارك هذه الفكره المعارضه سوف تكون من
واشنطن لكن يمكن تحديد الرفض الاميركي في
مقابل يعني مفاوضات همم
ودي قصه يعني يمكن ان يتفاوضوا فيها مع
الامريكان يمكن ان يفردوها على الامريكان
بشكل او باخر اذا توافق النظام مع تركيا
مع الروس مع الايرانيين الى اخرهم
لكن الهدف الثاني انا ما بقولش ان ده سهل
ده امر صعب لكن بقول يعني هكذا يتخيل
الاتراك
لكن الهدف الثاني اللي هو اعاده اللاجئين
لن يكون الاتفاق والتوافق عليه بهذا
الوضوء وبهذه السهوله لانه لا يوجد هناك
ما يغري الرئيس بشار الاسد بشراء هذا
المنطق اذا انا توافقت معك ماذا يمكن ان
تقدم لي انت يا اردوغان حتى اقبل باعاده
كل هؤلاء اللاجئين كثير منهم اما مطلوب
للنظام في قضايا مختلفه ابسطها الهروب من
التجنيد او همم انه منضم الى جماعات تركيه
او جماعات معارضه خارج البلاد او حتى اذا
لم يكن لها مطلوبا للتجنيد ولا انه همم
يعني سافر وترك النظام في مواجهه كل هذه
الدهون
الاقتصاد السوري شبه متداع شبه منهار هو
لا يستطيع ان يتحمل استقبال مئات الالاف
بلضعت ملايين في مدنه وبالتالي لن يكون
مرحبا
على هذا النحو باستعاده كل هؤلاء اللاجئين
ولماذا لمجرد مساعده اردوغان الذي سعى
لاسقاطه لعده سنوات ولا يمكن ايضا للرئيس
بشار الاسد ان يرحب بفكره مباركه انه يعود
عدد كبير من هؤلاء اللاجئين الى الاراضي
التي يسيطر عليها الاتراك في شمال سوريا
لان ده معناها مباركه رسميه من الحكومه
السوريه بالسيطره التركيه على شمال سوريا
وتنفيذ بقى او يعني مباركه
تحقيق كل الاهداف التركيه التي اشارته
اليها منذ دقائق
الرفض مش جاي من الرئيس السوري فقط الرفض
جاي من الكورد والكورد جماعات ليست بلا
حول ولا قوه جماعات مهمه تستطيع ان تناول
عسكريا دبلوماسيا والديها اتصالات وعندها
قدره وخبرات كبيره جدا في اداره ازماتها
هم تعودوا
ويتم دائما التامر عليهم وهم فعلا بيقولوا
ليس لنا اصدقاء الا الجبال وبالتالي يا
جماعات يعني اكتسبت مهارات
استثنائيه من الصعوبات الكثيره التي مروا
بها همم في سوريا وفي غير سوريا ودي قصه
يعني تستحق ان اتوقف عندها لاحقا ثم انه
القوى الاخرى الامريكان سوف يرفض فكره
توطين لاجئين واقامه منطقه امنه على هذا
التصور التركي لن يكون محل ترحيب من روسيا
ولا من ايران
في تعارف الاولويات اضف الى كل ذلك ان
المهاجرين انفسهم اللاجئين انفسهم لن
يرحبوا بالتنازل عن اماكن وجودهم المستقره
في المدن التركيه ليكونوا جزءا من مخطط
تركي
ويذهبوا الى مدن يعني هي محل نزاع ويتركوا
فرص اعمالهم ليعيشوا في اماكن يكون فيها
في خطر شديد في اجماع على انه هذا
السيناري صعب جدا تحقيقه لكن الرئيس
التركي
بيسعى ويسعى الى لقاء الرئيس بشار الاسد
على امل ان يحقق الهدفين الهدف الاولاني
يمكن ان يقطع فيه مسافه والهدف الثاني
قدامه مجموعه من السيناريوهات ممكن ان
يحاول على امل ان يتحقق السيناريو كاملا
ودي تكون يعني رغم الصعود الشديده سوف
تكون يعني انجاز ضخم جدا لرئيس التركي
ويدرك ان هذا صعب جدا جدا ان يتحقق ان لم
يكن مستحيلا لكن اذا لم يتحقق كله يمكن
حقا جزئيا وسوف يكون هذا ايضا انجازا كيف
يمكن ان يتحقق جزئيا باستعاده مجموعه من
اللاجئين في العمق السوري باستعاده جزء
اخر في الاماكن التي يسيطر عليها الاتراك
في شمال سوريا جزئيا
ويمكن ان لا يتحقق ابدا لا عوده اللاجئين
لا جزئيه ولا كليا لا في العمق السوري ولا
في شمال سوريا ويمكن حتى الا يتوافق بشار
الاسد واردوغان حتى على القضيه الكرديه
ويمكن للقوى الخارجيه ان تفشل كل هذه
المخططه وايضا في هذه الحاله سوف يكون
اردوغان مستفيدا مستفيدا حتى لو لم يحقق
اي شيء من لقائه مع الاسد لقاء الاسد في
حد ذاته يعني سحبا للبساط من تحت اقدام
المعارضه التي تريد خوض الانتخابات
بحزمه من الوعود منها اعاده اللاجئين
السوريين الى بلدانهم لقاء الاسد وقبله
لقاء وزراء الخارجيه وقبله لقاء وزراء
الدفاع الذي تم بالفعل في 28 و29 ديسمبر
باساطه روسيه يعني رساله واضحه من الحزب
الحاكم واردوغان داخل التركي مطالبه ما
يشغلك على قمه اولوياتي
وبصار التطبيع مع بشار الاسد تمهيدا
لتحقيق ما يشغلكم وهو اعاده اللاجئين
السوريين الى بلدانهم
فاذا كان اللقاء في همم يونيو المقبل ولم
يتحقق اي شيء سوف يكون اردوغان قد حصل على
اصوات الناخبين همم ووصل بالفعل الى قصر
الرئاسه ثم لكل حادث حديث وتبقى مشكله
الاكراد كما هي سوف يظل الاكراد في فوهات
المدافع التركيه والحقيقه مادافع اخرى
كثيره لكنهم تعودوا على ذلك
ويبقى مصير اللاجئين السوريين في تركيا
على صفيح ساخن وهذه قضيه تستحق انه
يناقشها في حلقات اخرى ان شاء الله اشكركم